So here's our update rules what they end up being.
The gradient descent rule we just derived says what we
want to do is more the weights in the negative
direction of the gradient. So if we negate that expression
that we had before and take a little step in
that direction we get exactly this expression. Multiply the. The
input on that weight times the target minus the activation.
Whereas in the perceptron case what we were doing is taking
that same activation, thresholding it. Like,
determining whether it's positive or negative.
Putting in a zero or a one. And putting that in here, that's
what y hat is. So really it's the same thing except in one
case we have done the thresholding and in the other case we have
not done the thresholding. But we end up with two different algorithms
with two different behaviors. The perceptron
has this nice guarantee. A finite convergence,
which is a really good thing, but that's only in the case where
we have linear separability. Whereas the
gradient descent rule is good because, calculus.
>> [LAUGH].
>> I guess that's not really an answer is it. It's, the
gradient descent rule is good because it's more. Robust. To to data sets
that are not linearly separable, but it's only going to converge in the limit.
To a local optimum. Alright is that, is that the story there Charles?
>> As far as I'm concerned.